ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE AUGUST TWENTY EIGHTH
HEARING NOTING THE ABSENCE OF A
QUORUM WE WILL GO AHEAD AND
START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE WE HAVE
TWELVE BILLS CONSIDER THIS
MORNING AND MISTER ALLEN. IN
YOUR FIRST SINCE YOU'RE ALREADY
THERE. YOU'LL BE PRESENTING ON
SB SIX SIXTY FOUR. WE'RE DOING
ALL SOME DIFFERENT ON THIS SO
WE'RE GOING TO AFTER YOUR
PRESENTATION BUT IF THERE IS A
MOTION WE WILL MOVE THIS TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR OF A APPRECIATE
THAT I'M HAPPY TO TALK PROBABLY
ABOUT THIS AT THIS THIS BILL
DEFENDS THE VITAL PUBLIC
INTEREST IN THE OPERATION AND
MAINTENANCE OF CALIFORNIA'S
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE.
BY AFFIRMING REGIONAL AGENCIES
THE ONES THAT SERVE ALL OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS TRANSPORTATION
NEEDS HAVE CLEAR AUTHORITY TO
RESPONSIBLE USE PERSONAL
INFORMATION DURING THEIR DAY TO
DAY ACTIVITIES TO OPERATE TOLL
AND TRANSIT SYSTEMS ON THE
PUBLIC'S BEHALF. AS THE
COMMITTEES ANALYSIS OUTLINES IT
IS QUITE UNLIKELY THE STATE
WILL FACE DIRECT COSTS AS A
RESULT OF THIS BILL HOWEVER I
AM BEFORE YOU BECAUSE- A LIST
OF LITIGANTS SOME PETITIONING
FOR CLASS ACTION STATUS OF FILE
CLAIMS AGAINST NUMEROUS.
REGIONAL TOLL AGENCIES AND
CONTRACTORS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE ALLEGEDLY ALLEGING
VIOLATIONS THAT LITTLE IMPERIL
BILLIONS IN TAXPAYER DOLLARS
AND JUST TO GIVE YOU A SENSE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE SHARING
OF NAMES AND ADDRESSES FOR THE
IMPROV INTER OPERABILITY OF A
FAST TRACK. YOU KNOW BOX WAR
FOR TOLL COLLECTION THAT SORT
OF THING. SO I IN THE MIDST OF
THESE LAWSUITS A CERTAIN
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL WOULD
APPLY RETROACTIVELY IN THE
SECTIONS DESERVE VERY VERY
CAREFUL SCRUTINY BY ALL OF US.
ALL OF US TO ENSURE THAT
GRANTING RETROACTIVITY IS
INDEED IN THE PUBLIC INTEREST.
NOW MY STAFF AND I HAVE ASKED A
PLAINTIFFS IN THESE CASES TO
DEMONSTRATE THE CONSUMER HARM
TO THEIR CLIENTS HAVE SUFFERED
AS A RESULT OF THE MILLIONS OF
ALLEGE PRIVACY VIOLATIONS. AND
WE'VE YET TO BE SHOWN ANYTHING
TANGIBLE. I ABSENT CLEAR
EVIDENCE THE CALIFORNIA BETTER
OFFICE BILLIONS OF TAX DOLLARS
ARE IMPERILED. SB SIX SIXTY
FOUR PROVIDES AN IMPORTANT
CLARIFICATION A STATE LAW TO
CONTINUE ALLOWING
TRANSPORTATION AND TRANSIT
AGENCIES TO USE. NAMES AND
ADDRESSES THAT KIND OF PERSONAL
DATA EFFICIENTLY WHILE
MAINTAINING APPROPRIATE
PROHIBITIONS AGAINST IMPROPER
SHARING. OF THAT INFORMATION
WORK VERY CLOSELY ENGAGED WITH
THE SENSE OF NEGOTIATIONS WITH
POLICY COMMITTEE STAFF FROM
PRIVACY COMMITTEE. AND
OPPONENTS OVER THE PROVISIONS
OF THIS BILL ASK FOR THIS
COMMITTEE'S INDULGENCE PERMIT
THOSE CONVERSATIONS TO
CONTINUE. BY SENDING THE BILL
OVER TO THE RULES COMMITTEE AS
WAS STATED BY THE CHAIR. TODAY
WHILE THE NOW SAYS NOTES THE
MAKING THIS A TO YOUR BILL
MIGHT PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR STAKEHOLDERS TO WORK OUT
THEIR DIFFERENCES. I DO BELIEVE
THAT CERTAIN DISAGREEMENTS OVER
RETRO TICKET ACTIVITY IN THIS
BILL WILL BE IMPOSSIBLE TO
FULLY RESOLVE. AND I'M
OPTIMISTIC THAT WE ARE MAKING
REAL PROGRESS TO ELEVATE
IMPROVE MANY TOLL AGENCY BEST
PRACTICES IN THE SYSTEM STANGEL
FASHION. MOVING FORWARD IN THAT
WE CAN GET THIS DONE OVER THE
NEXT COUPLE WEEKS. AS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. I TO THE MOTION. THANK
YOU SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE AND I WANT TO
BE CLEAR AND I'M SORRY BECAUSE
THIS IS SO UNUSUAL. SO. YOU CAN
SPEAK OF COURSE IN SUPPORT BUT
IT'S OBVIOUSLY NOT A POLICY
COMMITTEE. IT'S A FISCAL IN THE
FISCAL IS INCOMPLETE IN THAT WE
EXPECT ADDITIONAL. MOVEMENT
RULES AND WOULD HAVE TO COME
BACK SO ALTHOUGH YOU CAN SPEAK
I WOULD SUGGEST THERE'S NOT A
LOT OF ROOM ON WHAT. WOULD MAKE
SENSE TO SPEAK ON OKAY THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH MA'AM
CHAIR. SO I'LL JUST HIGHLIGHT
THAT TO MAKE IT VERY CLEAR THAT
THEY HAVE BEEN NO BREACHES OF
PRIVACY SALES OF CONCERTS OF
CUSTOMER DATA. DATA FOR
CONSUMER HAN HAS CENTER ALLEN
POINTED OUT. RESULTING FROM OUR
AGENCIES TOWING OPERATIONS
HOWEVER CLARIFICATIONS TO THE
EXISTING STATUTES ARMY IT TO
RESOLVE CERTAIN GRAY AREAS IN
THE VERBIAGE. IN THIS GRAY AREA
IS WHAT THE VARIOUS LAWSUITS
THAT HAVE BEEN TARGETED AGAINST
AGENCIES HAVE SOUGHT TO
EXPLOIT. SO SENATE BILL SIX
SIXTY FOUR WOULD CLARIFY THESE
ISSUES AND ALLOW US TO PERFORM
OUR DAILY FUNCTIONS OF TOLL
OPERATIONS. COLLECTING TOLLS
ENFORCING THE PAYMENT TOLLS AND
SUPPORTING STATE MANDATED INTER
OPERABILITY. SO WE WOULD LIKE
TO THANK CENTER ALLEN FOR
BRINGING ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS
TOGETHER ON THIS ISSUE. AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO FINALIZING A
MINUTES OVER THE NEXT FEW DAYS
TO ADDRESS THE REMAINING
ISSUES. SO WITH THAT ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA'S TOLD. AGENCIES
I WOULD ASK THE COMMITTEE
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR BACK
ALONG WITH THE BAY AREA TOLL
AUTHORITY. REALLY JUST HERE TO
THANK THE CHAIR FOR HER
RECOMMENDATION TO MOVE THE BILL
FORWARD TO THE RULES COMMITTEE.
THANK CENTER ALLEN FOR CARRYING
THIS BILL IT'S OF VITAL
IMPORTANCE TO THE BAY AREA AND
TO THE STATE. TOLLS ARE THE
LIFE BLOOD FOR TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM AND FOR MOBILITY SO JUST
THANK YOU AND I'M JUST HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY.
THINK YOU ADDITIONAL
SUPPORTERS. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
ENTER INTO HERE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY. IN SUPPORT. STEVE
BAKER THIRD REDUCES HIS FOR THE
PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS IN
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT IN
SUPPORT. I'M SURE MEMBERS MORE
TOP ON BEHALF OF THE ORANGE
COUNTY TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
IN SUPPORT. MORNING KIRK LIKE
WHEN I'M HAVE THE SAN DIEGO
ASSOCIATION OF GOVERNMENTS AND
AGAIN SUPPORT. A STEVE ALL COME
WE HAVE TO GO TO GET BRIDGE
DISTRICT IN THE ON THE ACCOUNT
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION
SUPPORT. MICHAEL PAYMENTS ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. YEAH
IT'S ALL OF ON BEHALF OF THE
SENATE CISCO BAY AREA WATER
EMERGENCY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY IN SUPPORT. ROSS
TALKING ABOUT THE SANTA CLARA
VALLEY TRADITION THIRTY AND I
HAVEN'T HEARD KIND
TRANSPORTATION THIRTY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU ANY SPEAKERS
IN OPPOSITION ONCE AGAIN I
WOULD SUGGEST THAT. AND YOU CAN
COME UP ABSOLUTELY THERE'S JUST
A VERY LIMITED AMOUNT OF.
ISSUES TO SPEAK ON AT THIS
POINT I THINK. WHY YOU'RE
GETTING THERE WE'RE GONNA GO
HEAD ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND
SECRETARY. GONZALEZ BIGELOW
BLOOM. BONTA BROUGH CALDERON
CARRILLO CHAU DEEP EGGMAN FONG
GABRIEL GARCIA MAIENSCHEIN
OBERNOLTE PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK
HERE RIVAS. MOVE YOUR BILL. AND
RE REFER TO SEVEN MOTION BY
MISTER BIGELOW TO MOVE THE BILL
TO AGREE REFERRAL TO RULES AND
A SECOND BY A DOCTOR QUIRK AND
I JUST WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR BEING SO TIMELY
THIS MORNING. BUT THAT. THE
OPPOSITION I'M ON THE RIVER FOR
ALL TO RULES YES I THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MICRO WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY. WE APPRECIATE THE THAT
YEAR'S PROPOSALS THAT IT MOVE
THIS BILL RULES WE DO NOT THINK
IT'S READY FOR CONSIDERATION
BOB WE ARE DEEPLY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE PROVISIONS OF THE
BILL THAT WOULD TAKE. WE CAN
NOTICE REQUIREMENTS AND CURRENT
LAW WE ACTUALLY THINK THERE IS
SIGNIFICANT HARM THAT HAS BEEN
OCCURRING TO OUR CLIENTS IN
THAT AREA WHERE PEOPLE ARE
GETTING CIVIL PENALTIES
IMPOSED. AND EXPANDING THE
ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO GO
RETROACTIVE WOULD CREATE MORE
HARM FOR THOSE REASONS WE
SUPPORT THE MOVE TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE AND GIVE THIS BILL
MORE TIME FOR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU JUST OPPOSITION OR. I
GUESS YOU'RE SUPPORTING BUT- NO
ONE WAS LOOKING BUT- YOU'RE
SUPPORTING THE I'M SUPPORTING
YOUR MOTION BUT I'M NOT. IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. EIGHT THIS
BEING SENT TO RULES I'M HERE TO
PUT THIS BILL I'M BEEN TRAVIS
ONE OF THE ATTORNEYS
REPRESENTING THE PLAINTIFFS IN
SEVERAL LOCATIONS INCLUDING
REPRESENTING A CERTIFIED CLASS
IN ORANGE COUNTY AND WE ALSO
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS NOT READY
FOR A FLOOR VOTE. THE CONSUMER
HARM AND YOU KNOW THAT THESE
ISSUES OF IT REACHES A PRIVACY
ARE BEING LITIGATED THE COURT
AND THAT SHOULD BE LEFT TO THE
COURT BUT THERE IS HARM BY THIS
BY THE PRIVACY BEING PEOPLE'S
PRIVACY BEING LET OUT AND
THERE'S NO EVIDENCE OF TAXPAYER
DOLLARS. BEING FORCED TO BE
EXPENDED ON THIS THE TOWARD THE
IN THE STATE IS NOT GOING TO BE
PUTTING UP MONEY FOR THIS SO WE
APPRECIATE IT BEING YOU KNOW
CENTER THE RULES FOR FURTHER
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION. TO
BE AN ATTACK OR THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA AND
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION
IN OPPOSITION. BY CRAMER MATTER
ON BEHALF OF A SILLY OF
CALIFORNIA AND ALSO CARS
CONSUMERS FOR AUTO RELIABILITY
AND SAFETY ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
BALK AT SEVENTY SIX IMPLANT
CATFISH THIRTY IN SUPPORT.
FINANCE THE MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE CHEN
ON THE SHOW THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WE DO NOT THE FILE AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU WE HAVE A
MOTION AND SECOND WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE MEMBERS I'M
AUTHORIZING THIS BILL BECAUSE
IT APPEARS TO ME THAT A LAW
THAT WAS PASSED TO SAFEGUARD
PRIVACY THAT I VERY MUCH
SUPPORT AND TO KEEP DATA
INTERNAL TO TOLL IN TRANSIT
AGENCIES IN THEIR CONTRACTORS
IS WORKING AS INTENDED. AND YET
THE SAME LAW IS NOW BEING USED
AGAINST PARTIES THAT FAITHFULLY
COMPLIED WITH ITS INTENT AND
WITH RESPECT THESE ARE PUBLIC
AGENCIES IS PUBLIC DOLLARS THAT
THAT IS THAT ARE BEING IN PERIL
SO I VERY MUCH COMMITTED THIS
CHAIR I'D COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE TO CONTINUE
REFINING WHAT IS BEFORE YOU
TODAY SO THAT IF THIS
LEGISLATION MAKES A TO THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR IT'S
RETROACTIVITY PROVISIONS ARE AS
CONCISE AND SURGICAL AS THEY
CAN BE I THINK THAT WE CAN
FIGURE OUT THE NOTICE AND CIVIL
PENALTIES ISSUES THAT WERE
RAISED BY MY FRIEND FROM THE
WESTERN CENTER. I AM VERY
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
I RESPECT LESS FROM THE VOTE TO
REFERRAL SO WE CAN CONTINUE
WORKING ON THIS THANK YOU AND I
WANT TO THANK YOU AND I HAD
EXTENSIVE DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
TOLL AGENCIES BECAUSE WHEN AN
ISSUE LIKE THIS COMES UP BRINGS
TO LIGHT A LOT OF ISSUES THAT I
THINK THAT OUR CONSTITUENTS
HAVE WITH TOLL ROADS IN GENERAL
AND THE ADMINISTRATION OF TOOLS
TO ADD. TO THEM AND WHAT A TRUE
TOLD E. VADER IS WHEN THERE'S
NO WAY TO ACTUALLY PAY THE TOLL
SO I A I APPRECIATE THAT
BECAUSE I ANTICIPATE IT WILL
DRIVE FUTURE LEGISLATION AS
WELL I WANT TO READ THE CHAIR
PUSHING SOME CONSUMER SOME
ADDITIONAL PRO CONSUMER STUFF
INTO THIS CONVERSATION HE ONLY
NEED ONE OF THOSE NOTICES FROM
THE TOLL AGENCY TO GET A LITTLE
DELIVERY PASSIONATE ABOUT THIS
SO WITH THAT THERE'S NO
QUESTIONS IN YOUR TO CLOSE LIKE
IT'S. OUT ON A ROLL CALL THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
MEMBER IN GET CENTRAL. SENATOR
WIENER. WILL BE PRESENTING SB
FIVE NINETY TWO. WE HAVE A
MOTION BY AFTER WORK IN A
SECOND BY MISTER BIGELOW THANKS
VERY MUCH BYE THERAPY SB FIVE
MADE TO MAKES CLARIFICATIONS
AND CLOSES LOOPHOLES IN THE
HOUSE ACCOUNTABILITY ACT AS TO
MINIMIZE COSTS AND I
RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR AND I.
THINK YOU'RE THE SPEAKERS AS
PART. MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
I'M ERIN EVENTS HERE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. ON BEHALF OF HOT
OF HABITAT FOR HUMANITY SANDEL
PROPERTIES IN CALIFORNIA BE
THINKING OF. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MEDICINE DAHLIA BEHALF
THE SILICON VALLEY COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT. ARE
THERE ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS. IN
OPPOSITION. MEASURE MEMBERS
INJURY ANTS WE HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF BEVERLY
HILLS AND OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
IN A FINANCE. FINANCES NEUTRAL
ON THIS MEASURE BUT NOTES
CONCERNS THAT REASON AMENDMENTS
TO THE BILL CHANGE LOWER
DENSITY CONDITIONS TO NOT
INCLUDE THE REQUIREMENT THAT
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS BE
SOLELY FOR RESIDENTIAL PURPOSES
WHICH MAY NOT RESULT IN
INCREASED PRODUCTION OF UNITS
RESIDENTIAL PURPOSES. THANK YOU
NOT ON THE POLICY BUT IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE ON.
ANYTHING ELSE I SEE NO
QUESTIONS RESPECT WITH WHEN I
GO BACK IT'S HAD ON A ROLL CALL
WITH MR MAIENSCHEIN NOT VOTING.
THANK YOU. MISS SKINNER. IT'S
GONNA BE PRESENTING ON SB THREE
TEN. IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION IT IS A MOVE BY
DR PARKIN SECOND BY MISS
CARILLO THANK YOU CHAIR JUST
QUICKLY THE BILL BEFORE YOU HAS
BEEN AMENDED IN IT PROHIBITS
NOW A PERSON FROM SERVING ON A
JURY IF THEY ARE UNDER ANY FORM
OF SUPERVISION SUCH AS PAROLE
FELONY PROBATION OR POST
RELEASE COMMUNITY SUPERVISION
ADDITIONALLY IT PROHIBITS A
PERSON FROM SERVING IF THEY ARE
A FELONY REGISTERED SEX
OFFENDER WITH THAT. I AM WE ARE
THEY'VE NOT DONE THEIR LETTER
YET BECAUSE WE JUST COMPLETED
THIS BUT I EXPECT THE DA'S IN
THE POLICE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION
TO REMOVE THEIR OPPOSITION IN
BE NEUTRAL IN WITHOUT I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU ARE
THERE SUPPORTERS ON THE FISCAL
ANALYSIS AND WE'RE GOING TO
LIMIT THISBECAUSE WE ACTUALLY
HEARD THE BILL LAST WEEK EVEN
THOUGH SO IF THEY DO YOU WANT
TO EXPRESS YOUR SUPPORT YES
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS NICK BROKE
I CAN BE HALF THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION CO
SPONSORS OF THE BILL. YOUR
SUPPORT IN HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. SIMILARLY
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MIKE A
DOCTOR OFF ON BEHALF OF THE
ACLU OF CALIFORNIA ONE OF THE
CO SPONSORS IN HERE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS THANKS SO MUCH FOR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT MANAGER
MEMBERS MIKE MONEY GOING TO BE
HALF OF THE METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION AND
ASSOCIATION OF BAY AREA
GOVERNMENTS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU ARE THERE ANY SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION. SCENE NINE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FINANCES
ON A FILE IN THE LATEST AMENDED
VERSION OF THIS BILL. QUESTION
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK
YOU IS NOTED IN THE ANALYSIS
THEIR MINOR AND ABSORB THE FULL
COST TO THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL IN
WITHOUT A ASK FOR EUROPE OF.
THANK YOU MISS SKINNER THIS IS
A MAN PUT THIS ON CALL BECAUSE
WE'RE WAITING FROM MR GARCIA
HE'S PRESENTING IN A MEETING
BUT IT. WE WILL BE ABLE TO AT
SOME POINT MOVE THIS OUT SO
THANK YOU THANK YOU. SO DOCTOR
CORT COURT IS GOING TO PRESENT
FOR MR BRADFORD. SB ONE FIVE
FIVE IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE A MOTION
BY I MISS CREATE A SECOND BY
MISTER OBERNOLTE. THIS CREATES
NO ADDITIONAL COSTS FOR THE P.
YOU SEE AND IT ACTUALLY MAY
SAVE COSTS IN THE LONG RUN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ARE THERE
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT. SPEAKERS
IN OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT
FINANCE FINANCE IS NEUTRAL.
WITH THAT THIS GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL THANK YOU DOCTOR
QUIRK I'LL TAKE A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. WE HAVE A
MOTION BY MISTER BREAUX WAS
OBSERVER OVER THERE I DON'T
KNOW HOW MUCH IT MOVED IN
SECOND BY MISTER OBERNOLTE.
MADAM SECRETARY CAN READ THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. SB SEVENTY
ONE AND SB THREE THIRTY SIX.
AND THOSE BILLS ARE MOVED. OUT
IN A ROLL CALL. IF WE CAN NOW
GET THE- ITEMS THAT ARE BEING
MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE ACCOUNT.
MADAM SECRETARY AB SIXTEEN
THIRTY NINE SB TWO NINETY FIVE
THREE THIRTY BY THIRTY EIGHT BY
FORTY TWO AND SIX FORTY SEVEN.
SO THOSE WERE ITEMS THAT WERE
MOVED TO THIS AS SUSPENSE FILE
WHERE THE AUTHOR WAVES
PRESENTATION IF THERE'S ANYBODY
HERE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
REGISTER THEIR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO ANY OF THOSE
ITEMS THEY MAY MOVE FORWARD
NOW. I'M REMIND PEOPLE THAT TO
US. WE THE PREFERABLE PUT.
THING IS TO STATE YOUR NAME AND
I'M ORGANIZATION A POSITION
HOWEVER YOU DO ADD THE FIRST
TWO PEOPLE ON ANY BILL HAVE THE
RIGHT TO SPEAK FOR TWO MINUTES
THAT'S MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
ENTRY ENTRY HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF BEVERLY
HILLS IN OPPOSITION TO SB THREE
THIRTY SKINNER. KAREN KLINGER
SACRAMENTO REAL ESTATE BROKER
ON. US SENATE BILL FIVE NINE TO
ANY TYPE OF HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT. WHERE IT
HAS TO DO WITH AFFORDABLE
HOUSING YOU MUST REALIZE THAT
THE COST. TO DO SUBSIDIZED
HOUSING TODAY SACRAMENTO THE
CITY. I BUILDING A FOUR HUNDRED
AND FIFTY UNIT SEVEN HUNDRED
THIRTY SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS.
UNIT MISS YOU MUST TO REAL LIFE
THE- THANK YOU THANK YOU THAT
WE PRESENT THE BILL WAS
PRESENTED ON AND IT WAS MOVED
ARE READY TO THE FLOOR BUT YES
BUT I REALIZE THAT THERE ARE
OTHER AFFORDABLE HOUSING BILLS
THAT ARE BEING PRESENTED AND
EVERYBODY NEEDS TO REALIZE THE
COST WHEN IT COMES TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THEY
NEED TO CHECK BECAUSE
SACRAMENTO IS A GOOD EXAMPLE
WHAT WOULD THE COST BE IN SAN
FRANCISCO. SEVEN HUNDRED THIRTY
SIX THOUSAND FOR EACH UNIT IS
ABSOLUTELY RIDICULOUS THIS IS A
FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY UNIT
COMPLEX THANK YOU THANK YOU I
WANT TO REMIND FOLKS UNLIKE
PERHAPS PUBLIC COMMENTED A CITY
COUNCIL. MEETING THAT THIS THAT
PUBLIC COMMENT IN THIS SECTION
HAS TO PERTAIN TO A BILL INS
SPECIFICALLY THAT WAS MOVED TO
THE SUSPENSE FILE AND THE
AUTHOR REYES PRESENTATION SO
GIVE YOU A LITTLE BIT OF LEEWAY
BUT FOR I'M GONNA. ENSURE THAT
THOSE RULES ARE STEP BY NOW.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR ERIN
EVANS. TO SPEAK ON SB THREE
THIRTY AND SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY SILICON
VALLEY AT HOME. THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA SANTA PROPERTY
COMPANY TMZ PARTNERS AND
CALIFORNIA CAN BE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. TO APOLOGIZE THAT'S
OKAY IF I WANT TO APOLOGIZE
BECAUSE SENATE BILL THREE
THIRTY WAS SUPPOSED TO BE HEARD
TODAY AND THE PUBLIC ARE NOT
INFORMED WHEN THEY GO INTO
SUSPENSE THE DAILY FILE THE
INFORMATION THAT THE PUBLIC IS
PROVIDED IS NOT UP TO DATE I
UNDERSTAND AND THAT'S GOING TO
BE TERRIBLY FRUSTRATING I DO
BELIEVE IT'S ONLINE. WELL IT'S
IS GOAL YES PUBLIC IS NOT
INVOLVED AND WE'RE NOT IT'S AS
THOUGH YOU DON'T. WANT US TO
APPEAR BEFORE YOU AND THIS IS
VERY. I THANK YOU MAN I
APPRECIATE YOU GIVING ME TIME
TO SPEAK THANK YOU THANK YOU
MA'AM AND AS I DON'T KNOW THE
LIFESTYLE. THE BILL I
UNDERSTAND. I UNDERSTAND AND I
THINK THAT'S A GOOD POINT WILL
TRY TO DO A BETTER JOB OF
EXPLAINING TO PEOPLE. WHAT CAN
HAPPEN IN WHEN YOUR TIME TO
REGISTER YOUR SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION FOR BILLS ARE BUT
YOU APPROPRIATELY REGISTER YOUR
OPPOSITION TO. PROBABLY THREE
THIRTY AS WELL I'LL I'LL TAKE
OF AS AN OPPOSITION AT THREE
THIRTY. AND IT IS NOTED
SOMETHING AND I WANT TO THANK
YOU THANKS. IT'S A LOVE FEST
TODAY. WITH THAT WE CAN MOVE SB
THREE TEN BY MISS SKINNER AND
THAT GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL
WITH MISTER CALDERON NOT BUDDY
MR MAIN CHINA VERY MISS
PETRIE-NORRIS BODY NOW WITH
THAT WE ARE WRAPPING UP OUR
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE GOOD JOB